gravitationswellen als großes rätsel der
physik und sie durchdringen die gesamte
raum zeit sie bilden die die
hintergrundstrahlung einen eigenen
gravitationswellen hintergrund wow und
mit dessen hilfe könnte es möglich
werden die geschichte und entwicklung
von galaxien aufzuklären ist es
astrophysikerin und physikern jetzt
endlich gelungen den mysteriösen
hintergrund von gravitationswellen
aufzuspüren klicks umsatz im future gibt
es dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's
herzlich willkommen vor mehr als 100
jahren wurde die existenz von
gravitationswellen bereits vorher gesagt
und zwar von albert einstein im rahmen
seiner allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
es handelt sich um stauchungen und
dehnung in der struktur von raum und
zeit die sich mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
wellenförmig ausbreiten die fachwelt
geht davon aus dass der urknall eine
flut winziger verzerrung der raumzeit
verursacht hat diese füllen noch immer
das universum aus und tragen spannende
informationen über die zeit unmittelbar
nach dem urknall mit sich und es kommen
immer mehr gravitationswellen dazu denn
wenn ein stern explodiert oder schwarze
löcher miteinander verschmelzen
entstehen ebenso diese schwingungen die
sich durch das weltall ausbreiten die
rede ist von gravitationswellen mit
ultra niedriger frequenz eine art
hintergrundrauschen also dass dadurch
entsteht dass im weltall unzählige
objekte gravitationswellen ausstrahlen
und diese überlagern sich jetzt gibt es
neue spannende erkenntnisse in diesem
zusammenhang ein internationales
forschungsteam hat nämlich ein
aufregendes signal aufgespürt handelt es
sich hierbei etwa um den sogenannten
gravitationswellen hintergrund sind die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
unter anderem auch vom max planck
institut für radioastronomie in bonn
also tatsächlich den gravitationswellen
hintergrund auf die schliche gekommen
das wäre eine kleine sensation und würde
uns ein völlig neues fenster ins
universum öffnen denn diese ergebnisse
könnten dazu beitragen die entstehung
und entwicklung von galaxien ja mehr zu
verstehen alle spannenden infos zu dem
nun aufgespürten signal gibt es jetzt
hier von mir angefangen hatte also alles
mit der relativitätstheorie von albert
einstein der die gravitationswellen
beschrieben hatte demnach produzieren
alle beschleunigten körper
gravitationswellen doch in den meisten
fällen sind sie viel zu schwach um sie
nachzuweisen angefangen beim start eines
autos bis hin zu einer sternenexplosion
am ende seiner lebenszeit die
entstehenden gravitationswellen stauchen
und strecken den raum etwa so wie ein
stein den man ins wasser wirft und der
die wasseroberfläche kräuselt aber vor
allem große objekte im all erzeugen
stärkere gravitationswellen schwarze
löcher und neutronensterne
wenn solche massen schnell genug
beschleunigt werden wird die raumzeit so
in wallung versetzt dass die
gravitationswellen auch noch in größerer
entfernung aufzuspüren sein müssten wenn
sich die vibrationen im weltall
ausbreiten wird alles was sie
durchqueren in einer richtung gedehnt
und in einer anderen zusammengedrückt
doch selbst wenn die gravitationswellen
sehr stark sind verformen sie das welt
als nur minimal doch einstein dachte im
leben nicht daran dass man irgendwann in
der lage sein könnte die winzigen
veränderungen zu messen die diese wellen
bewirken doch da hatte er sich geirrt
denn die messung von gravitationswellen
ist mittlerweile zur routine geworden
dass registrieren eines
gravitationswellen ereignisses pro woche
gehört mittlerweile zum alltag von
physikerinnen und physikern und das
obwohl erst vor einigen jahren 2016 die
erste sensationelle messung von
gravitationswellen bekanntgegeben worden
war wir haben das hier ja schon vorab
gemeldet das video ist hier unter me
2017 gab es dann zu recht den physik
nobelpreis an rainer weiss kippt vorn
und barry bis 2015 aber begann alles und
der große moment war gekommen der von
jetzt auf gleich alles veränderte nach
jahrzehntelanger suche hat man endlich
gravitationswellen gemessen ausgelöst
durch den zusammenstoß von zwei
schwarzen löchern und wie immer in der
wissenschaft ist solch eine entdeckung
noch deutlich mehr wert wenn sie
wiederholt werden kann und tatsächlich
auf folgende messungen bestätigten
als solcher kollisionen unter anderem
konnten gravitationswellen detektiert
werden deren ursache die kollision von
zwei neutronensternen war eine sensation
für die wissenschaftswelt allein durch
das belauschen der raumzeit schwingungen
waren forschungsteams von diesem
zeitpunkt an in der lage kosmische
phänomene aufzuspüren selbst diejenigen
die keine oder nur wenig
elektromagnetische strahlung freisetzen
das war der wissenschaftswelt bisher
verborgen gegeben seitdem haben die
beiden lektoren in den usa und der
wirkung sektor in italien zahlreiche
solcher raumzeit erschütterungen
aufgespürt meistens verschmelzen dabei
schwarze löcher mit dabei sind aber auch
neutronenstern kollisionen und sogar
auch die ungleiche paarung mit einem
neutronenstern punkt einen schwarzen
loch wurde so entdecken dennoch kommt es
immer wieder zu überraschungen und
rekorden so wie vor drei jahren 2009
sind damals gab es weitere vier
neuzugänge mit dabei auch die
massereichste und am weitesten
entfernteste gravitationswellen quelle
die bis dahin gemessen wurden die rede
ist von den ereignissen haben sgw 17 07
29 bei dieser verschmelzung wurden knapp
5 sonnenmassen in gravitationswellen
umgewandelt eine absolut gigantische
energiemenge die dabei freigesetzt wurde
entdeckt wurde sie in früheren
aufzeichnungen der gravitationswellen
observatorium laico und bürger in den
usa und italien solche spannenden neuen
einzel entdeckungen ergeben für die
fachwelt stück für stück ein gesamtbild
dieser super spannenden
gravitationswellen ereignisse dennoch
sind immer noch viele rätsel unter
anderem hat die fachwelt den sogenannten
gravitationswellen hintergrund im visier
doch der nachweis gestaltet sich als
äußerst schwierig und ist bislang noch
nicht eindeutig gelungen hierbei geht es
nicht um einzelne gravitationswellen die
bei individuellen ereignissen wie etwa
der kollision von schwarzen löchern
entsteht gesucht werden hinweise auf die
unzähligen und sich längst überlagernden
gravitationswellen die seite entstehung
unseres universums in unserem kosmos
unterwegs sind die rede ist also vom
sogenannten
gravitationswellen hintergrund ein
internationales forschungsteam will den
gravitationswellen hintergrund jetzt
endlich gefunden haben die kollaboration
aus wissenschaftlerin und
wissenschaftler mit der bezeichnung
international toolset timing eric hat
dafür jetzt neue daten veröffentlicht
und die haben es in sich denn sie
bestehen aus zeit messdaten von 65
millionen
handelt es sich um überreste von
massereichen sternen die sich hunderte
mal pro sekunde um die eigene achse
drehen dabei senden sie stark gebündelte
radiowellen aus um diese werden sichtbar
eben weil die pulse sich drehen
zahlreiche fachleute aus der astronomie
datenanalyse und astrophysik waren bei
dieser aufwendigen suche dabei und haben
dafür die größten europäischen
radioteleskope genutzt wichtig bei ihrer
suche war vor allem die kombination von
daten dazu sagt david champion einer der
beteiligten forscher das european
polster timing ist jetzt bereits ein
internationales projekt und wir sind es
gewohnt daten von bis zu fünf
verschiedenen radioteleskopen zu
kombinieren und sogar gleichzeitig zu
beobachten dieses fachwissen war bei der
erstellung der aktuellen
datenveröffentlichung sehr hilfreich
insgesamt konnten 42 pulsare und eine
lange basis von bis zu 18 jahren in die
untersuchung mit eingebracht werden
ebenso wichtig bei der suche nach dem
gravitationswellen hintergrund war der
detaillierten vergleich der einzelnen
datensätze von den regionalen
kooperationen mit dem kombinierten
gesamte datensatz genau hier wurden die
forschenden fündig es konnten deutliche
hinweise auf ein niederfrequenz des
gravitationswellen signal offenbart
werden und tatsächlich das signal dass
bei vielen kulturen gemeinsam auftritt
zeigt viele eigenschaften die die
fachleute von einem gravitationswellen
hintergrund erwartet hatten die analyse
zeigt dass sich das hintergrund signal
aus vielen verschiedenen sich
überlagernden gravitationswellen
signalen zusammensetzen diese stammten
von einer kosmischen population
supermassereiche binärer schwarzer
löcher gemeint sind damit zwei
supermassereiche schwarze löcher die
sich gegenseitig umkreisen und
schließlich miteinander verschmelzen
werden dazu sagt einer der beteiligten
forscher die johann chen dies ist ein
sehr aufregendes signal obwohl wir noch
nicht den endgültigen beweis haben
könnten wir am anfang davon stehen einen
hintergrund von gravitationswellen in
den daten zu entdecken doch final
geklärt ist das ganze noch nicht und die
forschenden sind sich auch einig dass
auch alternative interpretation nicht
ausgeschlossen werden können eine
weitere erklärung möglichkeit für das
signal könnte zum beispiel das rauschen
sein das in den daten einzelner klare
vorhanden ist und in den aktuellen
analysen nicht korrekt modelliert wurde
dazu ja nun gut der ebenfalls an der
studie beteiligt war die korrelation des
signals zwischen paaren von pulsaren ist
der schlüssel zum verständnis der
signalquelle gravitationswellen haben
ein sehr spezifisches muster das auf
andere weise nur schwer zu erklären ist
aber wir brauchen ein stärkeres signal
um diese korrelation nachweisen zu
können da ist also dass weitere
datenerhebung erweiterte netzwerke von
systematisch verbessern impulse und eine
weitere suche in größeren datensätzen
notwendig sind wenn es dann aber
gelingen sollte dieses spezielle branche
signal endgültig nachzuweisen wäre das
ein riesiger fortschritt die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
könnten mit diesen erkenntnissen die
geschichte und entwicklung von galaxien
aufklärt woher kommt die kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung eine ziemlich
irrwitzige geschichte denn die wurde
eher zufällig entdeckt wie das erfahrt
ihr in diesem video also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran